es klingt vielleicht werden witzig
begeistere mich für alles auffliegt
färbt schwimmt oder sich in irgendeiner
weise fortbewegt und genau deswegen habe
ich mich dazu entschlossen ab ihre züge
zu testen die schnellsten
außergewöhnlichsten oder luxuriösesten
der gesamten welt und bevor ihr euch
denkt was zur hölle macht er da es ist
deutlich größer als ihr denkt ich habe
ein komplettes vormacht in diese
richtung geplant und bin quasi um die
komplette welt geflogen das hier ist die
erste folge viel spaß
[Musik]
bevor wir mit dem video staaten vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren und mich
dabei zu unterstützen dieses jahr noch
die halbe million abonnenten zu knacken
ich zähle auf euch
[Musik]
das ganze ist kein witz wir testen jetzt
tatsächlich züge und wir starten heute
mit dem glacier-express
der glacier express oder auch fläche
express gilt als einer der schönsten
zugreisen der gesamten welt und eine
menge leute kommt extra für diese
erfahrung in die schweiz so auch hier
und was den besonders macht ist könnt
ihr direkt sehen er besteht komplett aus
glas und wir wären nicht auf meinem
kanal wenn wir nicht die first class das
beste vom besten gebucht hätten und
jetzt genießen wir vier stunden lang das
panorama und gucken ob sich das lohnt
für wen sich das lohnt und ob das laune
macht eigentlich ist ja schon
[Musik]
sie wurden direkt zum platz geführt und
haben da auch erfahren dass wir eine
servicekraft quasi für uns alleine haben
wenn ihr einfach nur vorbei schaut es
ist unser traum mit vier stunden lang
zeit die schweizer kunden uns
vorbeiziehen zu sehen dass alles auf uns
wirken zu lassen und dabei in drei gänge
menü mit weinbegleitung und bestimmt
noch viele andere tolle sachen zu
erleben dass wir ein absolutes fest zwei
minuten aus der stadt raus merkt man
direkt was diesen zug aus macht der
wagen mit riesigen fenstern so dass man
quasi 360° rausschauen kann in
kombination mit der schweizer kulisse
[Musik]
windows xp hintergrund aber die ganze
zeit so und erlebt halter fährt dann die
zieht an ihr vorbei
ok excellence class plus schweiz ist
gleich teuer das könnt ihr euch
vorstellen wie teuer das ganze war
erfahrt ihr am ende des videos wie wir
das ganze aber günstiger bekommen haben
erfahrt ihr jetzt nämlich mini gaal ist
ein cashback anbieter bei den über 1800
online shops gelistet sind und ihr so
bei fast jedem eure online-einkäufe
sparen dazu gehören er baut jugend media
markt oder expedia falls ihr reichen
buchenholz sowie ihr und natürlich noch
eine menge anderer shops und das ganze
funktioniert so wenn ihr mit igraal in
einem partnershop etwas kauft erhält
egal dafür eine provision diese wird bis
zum 90 prozent an euch zurückgegeben und
hier können so sparen also keinen daten
handle sondern so was wie definiert das
beste daran ist das ganze ist kostenlos
es kein abonnement kein vertrag ist ist
kostenlos und es bleibt kosten es gibt
eigentlich keinen grund das nicht zu
machen deswegen einen kurzes
rechenbeispiel bei expedia bekommt ihr
bis zu acht prozent cashback wenn ihr
also eine reise für 500 euro bucht
bekommt ihr bis zu 40 euro einfach so
von egal und sie müssen nichts bezahlen
hier bekommt einfach so 40 euro wieder
zurück dazu gibt es eine igraal browser
extension die euch bescheid sagt wenn
ihr in einem shop unterwegs sein wo es
cashback gibt und natürlich auch eine
app für ios und android über den ersten
blick in der video beschreibung und nur
über den ersten link in der video
beschreibung erhaltet ihr 10 euro
startguthaben anstatt der
standardmäßigen fünf euro dies sonst
gibt jack den link also austestet igraal
ist ein absoluter traum und gerade mit
hinsicht auf black friday und cyber
monday die jetzt vor der tür stehen kann
sich das richtig los vielen dank dass
sie nicht an dieses video hier
unterstützen und jetzt viel spaß
weiterhin mit dem video ganz kurz zum
bekommen umgeben vom 20 fans quasi 360
grad blick auf rom es fühlt sich
wirklich an als wenn man in der natur
und man sieht halt deutlich mehr als
wenn man in die wandermesse unterwegs
ist wir haben gefühl einmal alles
gesehen kühle natur was
ledger gletscher pässe wanderwege leute
die am anderen sind also ist so ein
bisschen so als würde man durch ein
reales kino fahren und das ist
unglaublich die komplette länge der
reise sind eigentlich acht stunden über
291 kilometern auf denen man 291 brücken
überquert von denen zwei sogar unesco
weltkulturerbe sind außerdem durchfährt
man 91 tunnel in der menge berge täler
und kleinere dörfern wir sind gerade am
dem kleinsten auf der schweiz vorbei
gefahren drei einwohner ein restaurant
das war's 30 kilometer müssen mit einer
zahnradbahn gefahren werden weil die
steigung bis zu 12,5 prozent ist von 500
meter auf über 2000 meter über dem
meeresspiegel man fährt quasi parallel
zu gondeln die einfachste trading berg
hochfahren und genau so macht das die
bahn eben auch wir sind ein großteil der
strecke gerade eben mit einer
zahnradbahn gefahren weil wir viel
bergauf bergab fahren mussten das ist
jetzt nicht mehr der fall deswegen wird
die lokomotiven gewechselt und wir
bekommen eine ohne zahnrad damit das
alles ein bisschen besser kommen
für alle wirklich zu begeisterten ein
kleiner ausschnitt vom motor ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung zahnradbahn 291
km und schweizer natur schön und gut
aber was macht die exzellenz glas
wirklich zur exzellenz glas
[Musik]
nicht gibt es nur bei einem begleitung
die quasi anhand unserer strecke
verläuft je nachdem wo man sich gerade
befindet kommt dann weiß rot rosé
[Musik]
jetzt sagen ja viele trüffel
kartoffelpüree und ein bisschen gemüse
zum hauptgang
der schweiz komplett neben von glas und
unwahrscheinlich
inklusive weinbegleitung jetzt droht
einigen
[Musik]
haben sie mir zu
machen
im gegensatz zu 1800 euro business class
gibt es hier also tatsächlich eine echte
küche mit echten köchin neben den drei
gänge menü und herr weinbegleitung waren
alle getränke und snacks mit
einbegriffen also immer wenn wir
irgendwas haben wollten konnten wir
einfach bestellen und in wenigen minuten
war sofort bei uns am tisch sitzt nicht
nur in der first class seine extraklasse
das bedeutet haben noch mal mehr platz
die sitze sind bequemer und jeder platz
ist direkt am fenster es gibt also keine
zweite reihe
großen super bequem werden eine menge
beinfreiheit und wir können den komplett
einstellen man kann sich auch quasi so
bis zu 65 grad hinlegen wenn man gerne
oben raus schauen will denn oben kamen
natürlich auch amerikas man sieht auch
dass ganz so guter stube
mit dem ipad konnten wir neben radio
hören und videos gucken auch infos zu
dörfern bergen tunneln und allen anderen
sehenswürdigkeiten entlang der strecke
erhalten das fazit es war krass aber
welche punkte vergeblich wirklichkeit
wie ein schweizer uhrwerk ist der zug
auf die minute genau eingefahren und auf
die minute genau auch wieder raus
gefangen also von fünf lokomotiven
verpflegung war ein absoluter traum es
wurde von echten kirchen in einer echten
küche komplett frisch zubereitet
regional saisonal es war ein absoluter
traum und wir haben wirklich
hochqualitatives essen genossen dazu die
bei begleitung dazu kostenlose getränke
egal was wir haben wollten kaffee cola
oder irgendwelche anderen softdrinks es
war ein absolutes fest ich gebe
was geht mich das
war schon fünf
verpflegung 55 kopf vor wir hatten sehr
bequemen sitz wir hatten eine menge
platz wir hatten dazu kleine extras wie
dieses ipad und so weiter das internet
hat funktioniert es sind alles sachen
die ich in den komfort in den luxus mit
einbeziehen es gab nur fensterplätze der
sind zwar einstellbar alles in allem
muss ich eine viereinhalb 5 geben wenn
man den sitz noch komplett nach hinten
hätte leben können wir es nicht von fünf
gewesen aber mit viereinhalb von 5 kommt
er auch ziemlich gut weg experience ich
hatte eine menge spaß es ist eine
zugreise und ich bin 22 und habe das
wirklich genossen werden denn
altersschnitt hat deutlich nach unten
gepusht habe auch für uns junge leute
war definitiv was dabei es hat eine
menge laune gemacht und für mich war die
experience eine vier von fünf
ja ich fand ja auch cool aber irgend ein
tourist hat mir noch gefehlt sauberkeit
was soll ich sagen das bad war ein
absolutes gedicht kennen das vielleicht
aus ganz normalen regionalbahnen icc es
das bad ist die absolute hölle in diesem
fall war das bad aber trocken natürlich
wieder saß noch in excel ins glas also
der teuersten klasse die es gab da wird
natürlich ein extra auge drauf gelegt
dass alles passt aber es war wirklich
überdurchschnittlich so dass einem die
sauberkeit wirklich aufgefallen ist
der preis wir waren in der schweiz sind
schweizer preise und ich so viel kann
ich schon mal sagen es hat sich trotzdem
gelohnt wir haben allerdings für diese
vier stunden zugreise
442 schweizer franken pro person bezahlt
das sind so viele euro es ist eine menge
geld und ganz ehrlich ich muss sagen
wahrscheinlich wäre es ihm der ganz
normalen klasse wo das ticket 150 euro
kostet genauso gut gewesen weil es mehr
um die kulisse und die erfahrung und den
zug aus glas steht die normale klasse
der exzellenz glas in nichts nach auf
der anderen seite haben wir es auch sehr
genossen das drei gänge menü zu haben
die rhein- begleitung sehr guten service
weniger leute in dem abteil ein bisschen
mehr ruhe weswegen sich auch im video
die ganze zeit leise gesprochen habe
reist man sich aber trotzdem zwei von
fünf geben einfach weil es unendlich
teuer ist für das geld machen manche
leute eine woche lang urlaub man muss
wissen und schauen ob man darauf bock
hat wir hatten bock darauf es hat sich
auch gelohnt aber es ist trotzdem
einfach teuer
insgesamt bekommt der glacier express
von uns folgende punktzahl freut euch
auf weiteren zu content in den nächsten
wochen vergessen also nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren um mich auch zu unterstützen
dieses jahr noch 500.000 abonnenten zu
schaffen vergesst nicht das video zu
leiten und dann sehen wir uns in den
nächsten tagen wieder
[Musik]